[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the director of the demos think tank
polly mckenzie and the jewish chronicles
deputy editor jake wallace simons
they'll be with us from now until
midnight thank you both very much for
joining us let's take a look and see
what is on the front of some of those
papers and the daily mirror says the
double child murderer colin pitchfork
has been sent back to prison after just
two months having reportedly breached
his bail conditions
the telegraph leads with the home
secretary saying asylum seekers will
have to obey strict rules at new holding
centers or face having their application
rejected
the times understands the prime
minister's ordering a review into the
current migrant situation
the guardian has an exclusive report
of rejection of multiculturalism by
success of governments that has helped
fuel the kind of racism faced by the
cricketer azeem rafiq
the financial times reports the surge in
covert 19 cases across europe is forcing
governments to take drastic measures to
curb infections with austria due to
become the first country to make
coronavirus vaccines mandatory
the daily mail has an exclusive claiming
a foreigner a former school governor has
been running an anti-vaccine group
that's picketed outside over a hundred
schools
the express carries predictions that
britain's shoppers will spend 85 billion
pounds on christmas this year
and the star hears that the comedian
benny hill's politically incorrect tv
sketch show is to be repeated for the
first time in decades
well uh joining me running around the
desk tonight polly mckenzie and jake
wallace simons thank you both so much uh
for giving us your time uh we're gonna
start with the financial times this
evening guys um and austria
is
going to make jabs mandatory it was on
the cards yesterday wasn't it polly um
will other countries follow suit do you
think
well austria has a particularly high
caseload at the moment and also
a particularly low vaccination rate
about a quarter of the population have
not been fully vaccinated they've got
about more than 140 000 cases
uh per 100 000 people which is you know
about twice what more than twice what we
have in
in the uk and and austria they have been
kind of
dialing up the tension uh around this
first of all having a a lock down
exclusively for those people who weren't
vaccinated and then being clear though
these rules won't come in until february
that now everybody they will expect to
get vaccinated i
i think you know other countries are
exploring um vaccine passports as
becoming a a way of limiting access to
behavior to
you know large spaces public buildings
for example as a way of making it all
but mandatory so that you're not kind of
crossing that final line i mean there is
a list in this ft article of other
countries i think it's tajikistan
turkmenistan the federated states of
micronesia and indonesia are the only
other countries that have gone all the
way to mandatory vaccination for all the
population though
we can presume that even in those
countries there are exemptions for those
people who are immunosuppressed and
therefore not allowed not able to take a
vaccine um i i think it will remain an
outlier approach but we will see lots
more countries going to that kind of
vaccine passports limiting uh limiting
access to
to busy spaces
and jake of course tied in with that
are those who haven't been vaccinated
some people are hesitant some people are
are you know full on anti-vaxxers and
their concerns about their ability to
carry on with their life if if different
uh countries start putting in these
regulations
yes i think i'm not going to be alone in
feeling rather uncomfortable about all
this uh you know hannah ahrens the uh
philosopher talked about how under
pressure there is an instinct towards
authoritarianism that must be resisted
and i certainly feel that that's being
seen playing out across europe at the
moment
thankfully not yet in the uk and
hopefully never will in the uk
i think we have to balance out the need
for um you know social responsibility uh
against the
the um requirement of having a free
country and a free
society um you know i'm nowhere near an
anti-vaccine myself i'm getting my
third shot hopefully
next week
but i feel that people who don't want to
take the vaccine their views have to be
respected they might have their own
concerns and their own legitimate
concerns uh about the speed at which the
vaccines have been rolled out and so on
and so forth
and i don't agree with them but i
respect their views i think that they
need to be
treated well and not made to feel like
second-class citizens and certainly not
forced to have a vaccine uh when they
don't want to have one
however polly if we look at the front of
the daily mail tomorrow it has a story
about anti-vaxxers that they're
describing as cruel
and menacing who are targeting people at
school gates i mean targeting children
but but i imagine by and large trying to
target their parents essentially
well actually you know we've had uh
protesters at the school gates where my
children are it's a primary school where
their kids aren't even eligible for
vaccines and i think it's it's partly
wanting you know kids do put pressure on
their parents around all sorts of things
um they put pressure on their parents
around the environment around recycling
right around uh wokeness all sorts of
things so actually if you can scare the
kids
uh with uh with leaflets with protest i
think it does have quite an effect on
parents as well as potentially affecting
the the kids whether they feel confident
taking uh taking these vaccines up
you know
jake i think it's i think it's
just
too much of a step to force people to
take vaccines and and actually what it
does is it antagonizes we see this in
the u.s in particular
where there's this amazing correlation
between whether you voted trump and
whether you're anti-vaccine and also
that's leading to a change in death
rates between democrats and republicans
that it's just kind of devastating that
politics can take us that far away from
you know the basics of good medicine
and i think an antagonistic approach in
the state risks alienating and dividing
people getting them stuck in their
trenches when the best outreach work to
people who are vaccine hesitant is about
respecting their views and being patient
and persuasive
let's move away from covid and on to
migration
uh jake both the telegraph and the times
are leading with this uh pretty patel's
plans for as the telegraph describes it
greek style clamp down
on migrants and the prime minister
saying um that and apparently the prime
minister uh demanding uh a fix on
migration from the home secretary
are you able to explain to us what this
greek style clampdown would be
yes i mean basically it involves um
setting up uh more rigorous
systems in asylum centers so demanding
that asylum seekers are back within a
curfew
monitoring them more closely with mobile
phones and apps and things
and really making requirements that they
have to fulfill
in exchange for being
put up and receiving board and lodging
and so forth while their claims are
being processed um and you know boris
has put his finger on a problem which is
disturbing a lot of people around the
country which is the continual arrivals
um over the channel uh by uh asylum
seekers and and migrants of different
sorts in dinghies and uh and ribs
which you know according to the
headlines has been hitting a rate of a
thousand a day on a couple of occasions
recently uh this is a big a big problem
uh not only because the uh the sort of
coherence of our borders is being
breached so consistently but also
because lives are being lost at sea
um and the uh incentive to reach britain
is what's powering uh people smuggling
and criminality which in itself causes a
great deal of misery not just in britain
and in europe but all over the world and
so something does need to be done for a
compassionate point of view as well as
the point of view of upholding the rule
of law
but i also would like to
make sure that i'm satisfied
uh that enough is being done to ensure
that we give proper refuge to genuine
refugees who do need um our help and our
protection at the same time i mean polly
i mean
it is clearly an issue and it's a really
um
an issue that many people especially
along the south coast who are being
directly affected by it really feel very
strongly about
but but you know
is there a wider question as to whether
we can ever solve this issue you know as
an individual country um
international migration is an
international problem it's a it's a
worldwide issue
is it ever going to be possible for the
uk to fix it for us
well i think that's right and you the
first my first thought on reading this
is it is a classic home office play
to blame all of the failures on other
people mostly on refugees or anybody who
has the audacity to aspire to a better
life we talk about economic migrants as
if it's the worst thing to be you know i
remember when conservatives said it was
good to get on your bike and look for
work nevertheless
what the home office doesn't do is
recognize their abject catastrophic
incompetence you know having sat through
on a couple of occasions a day of uh of
immigration tribunal cases
the the delays the incompetence the lost
paperwork the you know i i sat through a
case where um somebody who was married
already to her partner the home office
had turned down the immigration case
because there was no uh evidence of
intent to marry even though there was a
marriage certificate
that level of extraordinary incompetence
and you know we see this in the case of
the liverpool uh bomber outside the
women's hospital as well is that people
have their um
uh he had his appeal turned down and the
home office was incompetent and did not
manage to remove him and yet they blame
the asylum system which they run
in the end competence and there is one
sort of [ __ ] of light in this briefing
here which is they're talking about the
way that they have brought good data
management to asylum systems and digital
data management in greece and that
pretty patel wants to to replicate that
if she focuses on the competence of her
department i think she can tackle some
of these uh problems in it to the
limited extent that the uk can okay we
shall see
coming up lots more to discuss including
can cricket find its way back from the
racism scandal we'll discuss that
[Music]
watching the press preview with me now
polly mckenzie and jake wallace simons
we're going to start this half with the
financial times uh and jake its story is
about english cricket they say it is
undermined by racism um we of course uh
had the the revelations uh just
yesterday about azim rafiq and his
anti-semitic comments and he spoke to
you the jewish chronicle didn't he um
very very quickly what what was the
reaction of of your paper to to his
the words he said and the apology that
he gave
well i mean
he reacted extremely well to be honest
to these revelations uh it was almost
like a textbook uh apology you know he
gave his first interview to us the
jewish chronicle showing that he took
the needs of our community and the
concerns seriously
um he owned
the uh the thing he'd done all those
years ago and he apologized profusely
and when i asked him slightly probing
more probing questions like you know
was this just banter he said no it
wasn't it was racism i said you know
were you anti-semitic and he
acknowledged that he had some
anti-semitic views at that time so he
took full responsibility for it um and
then said that um you know he wanted to
become a sort of ambassador really
showing
people who still had that ignorance
which he ascribed by the way to not
having much exposure to jews when he was
younger
uh he wanted to show them that he'd been
on this journey and to help sort of lift
people out of those sorts of views so he
really was a very good response and he
seemed very sincere i have no reason
particularly particularly to doubt him
um i suppose the only real question is
whether um you know this was an isolated
incident of a few off-the-cuff comments
or whether it was indicative of a deeper
rot that was in his mind at that time
whether he did other anti-semitic things
and whether it was part of a greater
pattern and
at the moment it doesn't look like we're
going to ever really know that so it's a
subjective judgment that people have to
make whether they believe him or not
whether they take him at his word or
whether they give him the forgiveness
that he that he's looking for
and polly we've only got 30 seconds left
so just getting your action very briefly
but but when we look at the problems
that football has had with racism over
the years and how long organizations
like kick it out have been around and
how they there is still an issue do you
have any hope that the english cricket
board can make a difference to the
issues that it seems to have
i do and i think um
what differs from football is that
racism was always very visible
on on the stands in football and in
cricket it's it's actually been
in the clubhouse uh in the institutions
in a way that i think actually football
was just obsessed with performance and
it was the clubs wanted
diverse teams and the fans didn't it's a
different a different relationship in
qriket and i think that the fans will
put enormous pressure on the clubs now
that they've seen this disgusting
reality of what's going on
and and force reform
polly and jake thank you both so much